I do have I do have to say I wanted to
always say this to you is that um you
know arm when you sprung into you know
start um you know super stardom but yeah
super stardom and the Madison Square
Garden on that's not right
I've always said about you I've always
you know people go because people that
don't know you know how I wanted to say
this in the right way right some guy
that doesn't know who Dane Cook is then
they see this kid just good-looking
white kid who's energetic and physical
and crushing you think blow up and they
go goofy over they'll say something
right and I wish that would tell people
I go okay that guy's a [ __ ] beast
this dude right here is back in the day
I'm not aside from all the [ __ ] you did
and I'm not kissing your ass and I and
I've said that about other guys to where
you know you want somebody to go holy
[ __ ] like that's what he did to that
[ __ ] room especially the shows that I
would see you in he's in LA right where
it's jaded and you know you have so much
competition and it was cool to do
oddball even though you know we didn't
hang out that much you know I'm in but
it was I saw him you know Oh was he were
you part of the first class no we were
the last one the last no I mean on the
plane he's really good because he
parlays the laughs into the coffee
I know you're drawn blood everywhere
well yeah when we showed up at the
Burbank Airport yeah
do you remember you guys were all in
first class and I was in coach oh you're
yeah I was part of the very last one
that went out with Sebastian yeah but no
the first guy on the plane first yeah
right so they would like Tom Segura
would throw pillows at me but yeah yeah
yeah yeah because no one told me that
that like Maya manners is like no I got
the ticket then you know that I'm flying
out with a bunch of comics they're all
gonna have first class what would you
get me one bye sweetie it's two hours
right but that's yeah you guys made it
nice yeah yeah we felt great up there
you just feel great about her so it was
a funny were you laughing no yeah no
everybody put their headphones in it was
you Sebastian
Tom Segura what a great group yeah what
a great group yeah it was fun Oh glad I
could be a part of that one yeah it was
fun and I just couldn't believe that um
you we have you here it's like honestly
like I but it's it's of course cuz we've
had a long time and we know we've seen
battles we've seen you know
yeah man we've been on a lot of shows
with incredibly prolific comics comics
that aren't even with us anymore the
Freddie Soto's and there's a lot of
dudes we were we were on some really
significant lineups man so I'm proud of
our the legacy that we have laid and
just think of what's next that's what
I'm always excited what's next dad yeah
no you're right you know what you're
right and um and also the whole key to
the whole thing if you're young and
wanna do comedy and really is it's two
things if you're gonna work hard you
have to go up on stage obviously right
right but it's also just not they have
had years after MADtv you don't know
this about me I've had years that were
really bad like I wasn't making a lot of
money and I couldn't
anything going you know and then I've
had amazing yours you know its abs and
flows it goes up too but I never quit I
would never quit you know and you've
never quit yeah and that's the number
one thing you just gotta keep going if
you have the talent of course you know
because there's no where I think we're
always looking for some kind of end end
zone to make us feel like a real sense
of accomplishment yeah but let me tell
you a quick story about Jerry Lewis
Jerry Lewis was one of my favorite
comedians growing up the guy was the
biggest star in the world for many many
years with Dean Martin and he produced
and directed and he built technology and
he just a pioneer on and off screen and
I became friends with him in his later
years and it became a mentor and then he
became actually family to me so I talked
to Jerry Lewis once a week my childhood
hero I ended up getting into like some
really deep and he I could honestly like
I can hear his voice now on a low moment
in my life literally calling me and
talking me up back to a place where I
could function I went and saw him do his
show he was 89 he'd been in show
business ready 84 years at this point oh
my so 84 years every night Jerry would
do his show it was always the same show
and then the Encore was questions with
the crowd that was always new because
the questions were real and random so I
would go because I liked seeing how he
was during the Q&A and then it was 30
minutes all six times I saw him do it
and then the seventh time he did about
maybe 15 minutes and then the woman came
out took him by the arm and took him off
and I went backstage and again this is
just to show you this is what we are as
comics this is where we're always gonna
be Jerry Lewis 89 accomplished the world
yeah I go into the back he's stewing
he's literally sitting in a seat and
he's rocking and he's shaking his head
and I walk up and I wa Jerry Jerry is
everything all right he grabbed me he
goes they [ __ ] whip me early I had 15
more [ __ ] minutes for Q&A
still had we all my god you accomplished
your re on to the next thing in your
head so just revel and live in that yeah
you a new place get into a bigger place
yeah yeah yeah yeah do [ __ ] do it
alright
[Music]